on Monday president elect Trump held a
meeting at Trump Tower with top members
of the media the New York Post reported
quote Donald Trump scolded media big
shots during an off-the-record Trump
Tower sit-down on monday sources told
the Post it was like an effing firing
squad one source said of the encounter
Trump started with CNN chief Jeff Zucker
and said I hate your network everyone in
CNN is a liar and you should be ashamed
the source said the meeting was a total
disaster the TV execs and anchors went
in there thinking they'd be discussing
the access they get to the Trump
administration but instead they got a
Trump style dressing down the source
added according to the post attendees
included NBC's Lester Holt and Chuck
Todd ABC's George Stephanopoulos David
Muir and Martha Raddatz Fox News's Phil
shine MSNBC's Phil Griffin and CNN's
Jeff Zucker and Erin Burnett among
others here in no particular order are a
few random thoughts first of all the
media totally deserved this the media
destroyed Mitt Romney in 2012 by turning
him from an honorable family man an
excellent businessperson into the
scourge of the earth searching far and
wide for gay kids so he could practice
his haircutting skills hunting down dogs
to strap them to his car the media then
decided to treat Barack Obama with kid
gloves for eight years
soft peddling his lies on everything
from Obamacare to Benghazi then finally
the media built up Donald Trump in the
primaries and then attempted to tear him
down in the general they've earned every
bit of scorn Trump can level at them
second Trump's going to start every
single firefight he can the media didn't
leak this story to the post gang Trump's
people certainly did the post was one of
the friendliest publications in the
country to trump and this bolsters
Trump's favorite case that he's a
powerful god king willing to face down
the scurrilous media and hammer them
into the ground
Trump relishes this sort of fisticuffs
is why he singled out reporters during
his campaign it's why he went to war
with Hamilton in Saturday Night Live
over the weekend Trump gets that most of
his voters are sick of watching the
media monopoly and they're more than
willing to countenance a present blatte'
president blasting away at the media if
it means destroying that monopoly third
the media will seek revenge by turning
up the volume the media just don't know
how to handle a Republican who doesn't
seem to care about their adoration their
solution thus far is turning up the
volume to 11 that's not working they're
treating every Trump tweet as
apocalyptic every Trump outrage is
plumbing new depths of Dante's Inferno
that only succeeds in making Trump look
justified and slapping them with both
hands then poking them in the eyes like
a member of the Three Stooges the only
way the media could cover Trump properly
would be to understate their case rather
than trotting out
Howard Dean - labeled Trump cabinet
appointees Nazis are covering Richard
Spencer's alright hate fest as an
extension of Trump World finally this is
not actually great news for Americans
despite the delicious shite in Freud
this is not good news
Americans are best served when the press
of every stripe have access to
information about the executive branch
closing off access for political gain
was bad when Obama did it and it isn't
good when Trump does it many
conservatives can't see past their own
short lling over the media shamefaced
least shuffling from from tower tails
between their legs which is
understandable but the presidency is
still a government office it requires
more daylight not less so here's the
bottom line the lesson you ought to be
worried about a president who's not
granting access to the press even if
they're happy that he's slapping them
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show oh so much to get to today it's
gonna be an epic epic day for good Trump
bad Trump epic day for good Trump bad
Trump so once again we say thank you to
Brendan tonight's the the author of the
good Trump bad Trump theme because
there's going to be so much indication
of that over the next four years I can't
even begin to describe it but first we
have to say hello to our friends over at
Birch gold so if you're interested in
purchasing precious metals because you
think that the stock market is
overvalued or the real estate market is
overvalued if you think that you want to
hedge against inflation if you're
hedging against volatility in the stock
market then you need to put a little bit
of your portfolio at least into precious
metals the people at Birch gold are
folks who can help you move your 401k or
IRA into a into precious metals without
the tax consequences they have a 16-page
free kit if you go to birchgold.com
slash Ben birchgold.com slash been
they've an A+ rating from the Better
Business Bureau a lot of five-star
reviews they're the folks I trust for
for investment in precious metals again
ask all your questions make sure that
you have all your answers before you
invest then when you're ready to invest
in precious metals talk to my friends at
Birch gold group birchgold.com
/ Ben ok so just right off the top we're
gonna play the good trump bad Trump team
because there's a lot going on today all
right
[Music]
all righty so we begin with a little bit
of good Trump yeah good Trump see here's
the thing
folks I wish that I could spend the
entire show doing good Trump there's one
person who stands in the way of that his
name is Donald Trump you may have seen
him on TV Donald Trump does a lot of
silly silly things and in a minute I'm
gonna go over all the things that he's
telling the new york times as we speak
because he's doing some live interview
with with the new york times and they're
tweeting out the interview this is after
he spent most of last night ripping on
the new york times and explaining why he
wouldn't do an interview and then it
turned out that the real reason that he
wasn't doing the interview supposedly is
because why right his chief of staff
Reince Priebus told him not to do the
interview and then supposedly lied to
trump about the terms of the interview
because he thought that Trump wouldn't
be prepared for the interview and would
look stupid so this is going well the
chief of staff to the President of the
United States thinks that the
president-elect is too dumb to handle
the New York Times so he just lies to
him about the New York Times interview
this is according to Trump's camp okay
there's not according the press there's
what Trump is trotting out there why
because either one of two things
happened either Trump said I'm not
interviewing with those terrible people
at the New York Times or Reince Priebus
told him not to and lied to him and so
Reince Priebus his body goes ship right
under the Trump train so it's in little
pieces like Anna Karenina so that's very
exciting but we I promise there would be
some good Trump so we will begin with
good Trump so Trump has no outlined some
of his policy plans for the first
hundred days and it's a mixed bag here's
what he had to say my agenda will be
based on a simple core principle putting
America first whether it's producing
steel building cars or curing disease I
want the next generation of production
and innovation to happen right here on
our great homeland America creating
wealth and jobs for American workers as
part of this plan I've asked my
transition team to develop a list of
executive actions we can take on day one
to restore a laws and bring back our
jobs it's about time these include the
following on trade I am going to issue
our notification of intent to withdraw
from the trans-pacific partnership a
potential disaster for
country instead we will negotiate fair
bilateral trade deals that bring jobs
and industry back onto American shores
on energy I will cancel job-killing
restrictions on the production of
American energy including shale energy
and clean coal creating many millions of
high-paying jobs
so here's a bit of the mixed bag right
so on energy policy this is great right
when you talk about getting rid of these
restrictions now the truth is that the
biggest problem the fracking industry
faces right now is not regulation
although the regulation should go the
biggest problem they face is that the
price of gas is minuscule I mean because
all of the OPEC countries are attempting
to out pump each other
thanks to foreign policy Saudi Arabia is
trying to pump around into the ground
around trying to pump Saudi Arabia into
the ground that means there's a glut of
oil and that means that the prices have
gone down so the profit margin and
fracking has gone down too so that's the
biggest problem facing the fracking
industry is actual pricing in the market
not the regulations but it's good the
Trump is saying that on the bad side
when he talks about TPP and revoking it
there are only two reasons to oppose TPP
okay reason number one is that it
included a lot of secret side clauses
that Obama had negotiated and reason
number two is because the Congress of
the United States should actually have
the entire agreement in front of them
before they before they approve it and
they didn't in the case of TPP the idea
that we're gonna pull out of
multilateral trade agreements and then
just negotiate bilateral trade
agreements that are fair for us okay
what when Trump says fair for us what he
means is he wants to make foreign
products more expensive for you the
consumer because he wants to protect
certain classes of people in the United
States so he wants to protect steel
workers in Ohio or Farm Workers in Iowa
okay when Democrats do the sort of
subsidies that's bad when Republicans do
that sort of subsidies it's also bad so
I'm not in favor of this kind of stuff
cracking down on free trade is just a
welfare program for people who are
protected okay so it really helped
economies to put up tariffs see if it
really helped economies then the
greatest economy on earth would be
Venezuela Venezuela has tariffs on
virtually every product and people are
literally eating dogs they're shooting
dogs and eating them the fact is that
you as an American have the freedom and
the ability to purchase any product you
like in the marketplace at the lowest
price that you can find that's one of
the things that's beautiful about
free-market capitalism
Trump doesn't get that so there's the
mixed bag but he said some other stuff
that's good he talks about how he wants
a plan on security to harden the
infrastructure with regard to terrorist
attack this is talking about the idea of
electrical grids being vulnerable to
terrorist attack oh that's good there
are a few things he didn't mention he
didn't mention the wall
he didn't mention getting rid of Obama's
executive amnesty he didn't mention
tearing up the Iran deal so a lot of the
big promises he made he completely
ignored but you know what he said here I
would say about 70 percent of this is
correct so good good for him
other a good Trump so there's a cop that
was shot in San Antonio died and Trump
immediately called the family of the cop
that is a major shift from President
Obama who spent most of his tenure
reaching out to the people who are shot
by cops
both rightly and wrongly and making the
cops into the issue Trump is not going
to do that that is a very very good
thing so good for Trump for doing that
other good things that Trump's doing
Trump met yesterday with the founder of
Black Entertainment Television and this
is smart
again this is Trump doing outreach and
outreach is a good thing for Republicans
to do does it disturb you I didn't get
your arms around the fact that you've
got people like that supporting him but
but you had what you described as a
positive Frank and candid meeting and
you think he's committed to reaching out
to black America you know as an African
American who's been in business and had
to come up and grow up from someone who
was the first to go to college to to
create successful businesses and create
wealth for myself and a number of other
African Americans I know that there are
people like that in America it's been
that way a business slavery existed in
this case they're not going to go away
to tomorrow or the next day okay so he
actually came out and he said that he
was happy they met with Trump and
they're hoping that they can work
together I gettin smart up Trump to
reach out in that way okay so all of
that is good Trump or at least decent
Trump know it's time for some bad Trump
oh so a few things to begin first of all
you remember that the Trump had in Mitt
Romney to the White House and and said
that he wanted to or to to Trump Tower
and said that he wanted to consider him
for Secretary of State in this
off-the-record meeting with the press he
then started bragging that Romney
desperately wanted to be Secretary of
State he also had Kelly Ayotte the
senator from New Hampshire who didn't
back him and there was talk about her
possibly being Secretary of State or SEC
defense
and and Trump just said to the New York
Times we're not gonna use Kelly Ayotte I
don't even like Kelly Ayotte so he's
just bringing these people in to stomp
on their faces which is that surprising
no of course it's not surprising this is
Donald Trump you're talking about of
course Trump was gonna do this I spoke
with a higher-up in one of the these
people who is not a big trump back or
met with Trump and I spoke with a
higher-up in this person's team and I
said you should just be aware he's gonna
stomp on your face at the first
available opportunity yes yes he will
okay so start with that now Trump is
also backing away from you recall just a
few short days ago you recall stadiums
full of people shouting lock her up lock
her up lock her up about Hillary Clinton
remember I'm old enough to remember that
aren't you old enough to remember that I
think you are if you're watching this
show I hope you are because it's obscene
for those under the age of two weeks but
four but the bottom line is that now
Donald Trump is backing off of this
Kellyanne Conway was his campaign
manager now she's saying that Donald
Trump will not move for prosecution of
Hillary Clinton so before we even get to
this let me just point something out if
Barack Obama okay we're gonna use the
proper use yesterday this is the other
foot shoe right you remember this this
is the shoe that says take what Trump is
doing pretend Hillary was doing it and
then see if you're like if you like it
if Hillary Clinton had been elected and
she said I am NOT going to pursue
investigation of the Clinton Foundation
we would have said that's bad the
president doesn't get to decide those
sorts of things when Barack Obama took
office if he had said before taking
office I am going to tell Eric Holder to
ignore all possible prosecution of the
Black Panthers people would have said oh
that's bad you're not supposed to do
that the presidents of the United States
are the president-elect he's not
supposed to direct the Attorney General
to investigate or not investigate
anything by Kellyanne Conway she says
don't worry Donald Trump is gonna
prosecute Hillary Clinton again just for
people who don't understand the
Constitution prosecutorial power lies
with the Department of Justice the
president doesn't get to prosecute
people the Supreme Court from didn't
know this but the Supreme Court doesn't
get to prosecute people the Congress
only gets to impeach people okay they
get to they get to issue contempt orders
also but here's Kellyanne Conway saying
something that if Hillary said it would
be a little bit upset about I think when
the president-elect who's also the head
of your party now Joe tells you before
he's even inaugurated he doesn't
to pursue these charges it sends a very
strong message tone and content to the
members and I think Hillary Clinton
still has to face the fact that a
majority of Americans don't find her to
be honest or trustworthy but if Donald
Trump can help her heal then perhaps
that's a good thing help her heal I
didn't remember those chants in the
stadium's help her heal help her heal I
don't remember don't remember those
Kellyanne Conway by the way here you're
put on warning folks if you if you think
that Trump's gonna keep all his promises
you have now been officially warned by
Kelly on Conway she says well I do look
I think he's thinking of many different
things as he prepares to become the
president of the United States and
things that sound like the campaign
aren't among them okay so things that
sound like the campaign are not things
he's going to do way to say so what is
he going to do because I thought that
the campaign is where you tell people
what you're going to do I thought that's
what campaigns were for what was the
campaign for then was it just because he
liked speaking in front of crowds okay
see if I look he's not president yet
we'll hold off judgment on what he does
as president until we know what he's
actually going to do right but the idea
that you're gonna get all the things
that you wanted that Bert remember he
was saying this he actually said all
your dreams will come true if he's
elected well that first dream that
Hillary would go to prison there that
dream is not coming true because he's
actually actively interfering with the
criminal justice system so let's start
with that let's start with that okay
other things that Trump is doing okay so
the this interview with the New York
Times is truly astonishing and and it
just demonstrates that there are not
really the Trump kept talking to the
during the campaign about how he would
turn into presidential Trump how he
would just become magically presidential
Trump and I'm trying to be
intellectually honest no Ted no I'm
saying things that people don't want to
hear that's because we're being
intellectually honest here we're trying
to analyze this guy like he's the leader
of the free world or the president-elect
of the United States not like he's our
best friend and we're so excited he got
elected oh let's grant him all the
opportunity I don't believe in
honeymoons I don't I believe in that
when you're married I don't believe in
them in politics there's no such thing
as a honeymoon in politics once you have
power it's not my job to oh you support
it is your job to do your job for me you
work for me Donald Trump works for me
Donald Trump works for you we do
work for Donald Trump we do not work for
him we do it's not our job to support
him it is our job to say he's the
president of the United States and he
has governing power but that comes along
with some responsibility so it is his
job to live up to that responsibility
not our job to play nice with him when
he does not so just start with what he
is saying today in this New York Times
interview so first he starts with
ripping the New York Times okay that's
sort of normal then he talks about the
electoral college and then he starts
talking about the alt-right and he says
about his alt-right supporters so for
people who haven't been following this
show we were some of the first people to
expose the alt-right alt-right the
alternative right it's a group of people
there's a lot of people who identify as
all right who don't actually know what
the alt-right is right they think
they're all right because they like
memes and they don't like Paul Ryan
that's not all right all right is people
who believe in the philosophy of Richard
Spencer or Jared Taylor these are people
who believe in the philosophy of Vox Dei
they believe that Western civilization
isn't inherently and inextricably bound
up with European ethnicity they believe
that the only way to preserve Western
civilization is to have essentially more
white people that's that that's the
basic concept here and a lot of
alt-right people are very very excited
with Donald Trump they like Donald Trump
and the reason they like Donald Trump is
because Donald Trump has done a few
things we're sort of wing to nodded at
them so for example when he refused to
condemn the KKK the alt-right got a big
boost out of that when Donald Trump
hired Steve Ben and Steve Danon who's
his new chief strategist person I know
Bannon is somebody who is called bright
by at the platform for the all right
Breitbart his printed piece is praising
the alt-right and Richard Spencer the
alt-right neo-nazi leader basically
specifically praising Richard Spencer as
an intellectual right says so Steve
Danon in an interview at The Wall Street
Journal he downplayed the all right as
oh they're just a group of people who
don't like Paul Ryan and Mitch McConnell
and they don't care about small
government no that's not the whole thing
he acknowledged man and did yeah there's
a tinge of racism and anti-semitism to
the all right but that's just fringy
that's just fringy stuff
no the alt-right has a very specific
philosophy may mean what they say here
is Trump on the alt-right it's not a
group I want to energize and if they are
energies energized I want to look into
it and find out why hmm
I have a few ideas I have a few ideas
perhaps you shouldn't have hired the guy
who said that he created Breitbart into
a platform for the alt-right and then
proceeded to downplay what the alright
was in the pages of The Wall Street
Journal and then
say that the alt writes racism and
anti-semitism are not really part of the
movement okay that's that maybe that's
why the alt-right is really excited
about your administration and maybe you
should think about that a little bit
more deeply and then Trump reiterated
that he was not interested in
investigating the Clintons and then he
said that he's keeping his mind to open
on anthropogenic climate change so he's
saying that that the climate change
treaties he'll think about deeply which
is for sure Obama in his ear and then
this is the part that's truly amazing
right he was asked about his company so
we're gonna get into some of his
business conflicts in a second because
again if you want to see an actual
successful Republican presidency the
president cannot be impeached because
he's using the power of the federal
government to boost his businesses
that's a bad thing where I come from
that's a bad thing if you're rooting for
Trump to succeed you want him to
separate off from his businesses so he's
not involved in corruption
well we'll explain what exactly is
happening with that in just a second but
to do that you have to go over to Daley
wire calm and subscribe $8 a month gets
you a subscription you can watch the
rest of this show live you can be part
of the mailbag we're gonna be doing that
tomorrow we're gonna deconstruct the
culture a little bit later and you get
to watch us deconstruct the culture a
little bit later in the program eight
bucks a month buys you not only access
to the rest of my show live but also
Clavin show live on video you also get
to be part of his mailbag you also get a
free copy right now if you get an annual
subscription you get a free copy of my
book true allegiance sign and you can
frame it and it can be something that
you hand down to your children because
you once got a signed copy for me which
is amazing but daily wire.com is the
place to go if you want to subscribe
check it out right now
[Music]